[موسيقى]
التنين الاصفر يعلنها مدويه
سابتلع العالم كله ومعدتي تتحمل هضمه
والغرب يقولها في تخبطه الصين تريد ان تضع
الكوكب كله في جوال وتمشي به اصحاب العيون
الضيقه صنعوا نسخه من كل شيء غزوا اسواق
العالم بمنتجاتهم واحكم قبضتهم عليها ولم
يكتفوا بذلك بل غزوا بسلاحهم ملوك تصنيع
السلاح في العالم امريكا والقاره العجوز
واليوم تصنع بكين عملاقا مرعبا ظل ينمو في
الظلام وهي تعلن عن نسخه اخرى من قوات
فاغنر الروسيه ولكن على طريقتها ما هي
قوات فاغنر بكين المرعبه المنتشره في كل
قارات العالم وهل تستطيع التمرد على الصين
كما فعلت فاجنر موسكو مع بوتين وما هو
المشروع الذي يخطط له التنين الصيني الذي
يهدف الابتلاع كوكب في معدته وهل سيتركه
الضبع الامريكي يفعل ما يحلو له ويسلمه
مقاليد حكم العالم بهدوء لتعرف اجابه كل
تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو للنهايه
عملاق ظل ينمو في الخفاء
لولا تمرد قوات فاجنر الروسيه الاخير ضد
بوتين مظله قوات فاجنر الصينيه عملاقا
ينمو ويعمل في الخفاء دون ان يسمع به احد
فتمرد فاغنر الروسيه سلطت الضوء على شركات
الامن الصينيه المسلحه والتي اكتشف العالم
مؤخرا انها منتشره بشكل كبير في افريقيا
واسيا يبدو ان اصحاب العيون الضيقه
يتحركون في صمته ومعدتهم تتحمل ابتلاع
ثلاثه ارباع العالم
عدا امريكا الشماليه واستراليا تحميهم
اقمار صناعيه اينما ذهب وا ومسلحون باحدث
الاسلحه والتقنيات العالميه السلاح الصيني
رهن اشارتهم نعم تسونامي المستقبل وحاكم
الكوكب المنتظر ولكن كيف نشات قوات فاجنر
الصينيه وماذا تفعل في كل انحاء العالم
التنين الاصفر يبتلع الكوكب
عام 2017 ليسيطر التنين الصيني على معظم
اقتصاد العالم من خلال مشروع الحزام
والطريق او الطريق الحرير الجديد كما يطلق
عليه بكين تستثمر في مئه واثنتين وخمسين
دوله متفرقه بافريقيا واسيا واوروبا
وامريكا الوسطى والجنوبيه ولكن في الوقت
الذي انتعش فيه اقتصاد بكين وانتشر رعياها
في كل انحاء العالم كان للانتشار الصيني
الواسع مخاطره خصوصا في قارتي افريقيا
واسيا ففي باكستان تعرض رعيا صينيون
لهجمات مسلحه وعمليات خطف عديده بل وقتل
في بعض الاحيان وكان وضع العمال الصينيين
في افريقيا اسوا حالا فخلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه تعرض الكثير من العمال
الصينيين لعشرات الهجمات وعمليات الخطف
والطلب فديه في دول عديده بالقاره السمراء
كاليبيا ونيجيريا واوغ
تم قتل تسعه عمال صينيين في هجوم شنهوا
مسلحون على منجم ذهب اكتشف حديثا بجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى كل هذا دفع الصين لانشاء
قوات امن خاصه بها من اصحاب الخلفيات
العسكريه وارسالها الى الدول التي بها
رعاياها لحمايتهم وحمايه استثماراتها
الضخمه خصوصا في افريقيا التي تخطت
استثمارات بكين فيها 200 مليار دولار
سنويا وتخطط للمزيد والمزيد
اشباح الظل الصينيه
اسمها الرسمي ليس فاجنر انما هي مجموعه
شركات امن خاصه تتبع الحكومه الصينيه
افرادها هم من العسكريين الصينيين همام
محاربون قدامه واما عساكر وضباط مدربون
عسكريا على اعلى مستوى اطلق عليها اسم
فاجنر لانها تشترك مع قوات فاجنر الروسيه
في بعض الامور الفرقتين تربطهما علاقات
غامضه مع جيوش دولتيهما وكلتاهما تنفدان
عمليات سريه مسلحه خارج بلدهما وتمتلكان
نقاط دفاع بحريه في اماكن نفوذهما وكما هو
حال فاجنر موسكو فعمليات
العسكريه السريه تماما وقد يصل الامر
لاغتيال شخصيات رفيعه المستوى في دول
افريقيه واسيويه وكان اصحاب العيون الضيقه
يعلنونها صراحه من يقف امام قطار احلامنا
سيدهسه القطار دون تردد ولكن هل من الممكن
ان تتمرد اشباح بكين وينقلب السحر على
الساحر كما فعلت باجنر موسكو قبضه حديديه
التنين الاصفر لا يدع مجالا للصدفه ففي
الوقت الذي تمتعت فيه فاجنر موسكو
بصلاحيات واسعه وتسليح متطور ساعدها في
تمردها المسلح الشهير ضد بوتين لا تسمح
حكومه بكين الشيوعيه لشركاتها بنفس
الصلاحيات او حتى نفس درجه التسلح بل تضع
بكين تلك الشركات تحت سيطرتها المحكمه
وتملك في ايديها بوصله التوجيه ورغم
السلاح المتطور الذي سلحت به بكين افراد
شركاتها الخاصه ودعمها لهم بكل
التكنولوجيا الصينيه المتطوره فان كل هذا
يعد لا شيء بالنسبه للسلاح الذي يمتلكه
الجيش الصيني المنظم فباقنر بكين تستطيع
فعل اي شيء خارج الصين مهما كان خطرا ولكن
اذا ما فكرت في الانقلاب على الصين وربما
سيمحوها الجيش الصيني بسلاحه من الوجود
وقالتها بكين سابقا
قبضتنا الحديديه وصوتنا الذي نضرب به
اعدائنا دعمناكم باحدث انظمه المراقبه
واقوى الاسلحه لتكونوا اعيننا في الخارج
سنبتلع بكم العالم كله ولن تكون هناك اي
بقعه في هذا الكوكب بعيده عن ايدينا يبدو
ان التنين الصيني قد ضغط على زر الساعه
وبدا العد التنازلي لسيطره الضبع الامريكي
على العالم والسؤال لكم مشاهدينا هل ستنجح
بكين في انتزاع كرسي العرش من واشنطن من
الضباع الامريكيه سيكون لها رايا اخر
[موسيقى]